I'm in my wardrobe room here at Televisa
I'm on the soap opera me at 11:00
imagine what you would be like lovely
curse it's not your actual and I
specifically asked if I could play the
role of a very sexy man who has a steamy
encounter with a very beautiful Mexican
woman yes
you guys said no problem and came back
to me and I play a cheese merchant what
happened well the thing is that so give
me a little bit of the backstory this is
a girl that they mistakenly think that
she's evil and she grows up she becomes
a beautiful girl and is there any chance
that she will love my character theater
doesn't she would think Robert ego which
is happens to be it's Rodrigo her lover
her boyfriend her boyfriend but we can't
kill them in the story well Richard
[Music]
you can import our queso
okay so say you know sk aqui aqui no
some scarcity suppose leche a and form
our own colorss a link our guys Amiga
mía
over oh no sighs so yeah just gracias
hey Emily is it the beingness of chattel
[Applause]
G Johnson what's Augusto sell you rate
the French Kiran certainly was just
honest agenda telephony test okay kami
Toman el perro senorita mr. Rodrigo dijo
que aqui estamos because cable
television Oh si si si si si lo sabemos
Piroska
[Applause]
Canoga comparably Rodrigo truckwest
impresario que esta muy tres hombres que
no quiero proper car problems
si quieres about me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you